[Music]
the group Human Rights Watch released a
map showing the 13 states where peeing
in public could put you on a sex
offenders list this is a real story this
is the real map here's the map right
here oh those are the actual state where
people can be put on the sex offenders
list for peeing in public
now of course states they're all marked
in yellow now notice Nevada look at
Nevada right there Nevada as you can see
is almost completely surrounded by
states where public urination could make
you a sex offender and I'm not the only
one who noticed check out this new ad
from the Nevada tourist Commission some
states you can't take a leak outdoors
without folks thinking you're a pervert
but here in Nevada with over 7 million
square miles of desert sand open range
you can put out the campfire and siphon
the Python without wounding up on some
government free click that's why we
invite our neighbors from California
Arizona Utah and Idaho to green your
main brain in God's country and after
you've made your bladder gladder enjoy
Devadas exciting gaming from top-notch
entertainment or stay in your home state
just put your junk into Nevada cops
can't do jack
Nevada free to pee you and me
[Applause]
you
you